alright folks let's get started first of
all welcome to this webinar on
introduction to Amazon Web Services so
my name is savithri Surrey and I'm an
entrepreneur and but you know also been
using a pervious for about eight years
now and I'm a Solutions Architect as
well and just to tell you a little bit
about how I have used Amazon Web
Services so for about four or five years
I was involved with a software as as a
service business right and this was a
start-up and and in this in this role I
had to be involved on the technical side
with a young team so I was involved in
an architect and building it coaching a
team as well and also on the sales side
I had to communicate cloud computing
software services as an idea to
audiences which were not being familiar
with these these concepts okay and in a
subsequent role I was involved in cost
optimization of a tubeless and this was
for a large technology product alright
so today what I'm going to do is I'm
going to introduce you to a degress but
I will not show you any slides no
presentation this is going to be a
demonstration only alright and there's a
bunch of services that ADA base offers
but I will focus on maybe two or three
key services so let me just show you let
this turn let's get started right let me
show you this the screen I hope you can
see be a bit console the a placement
console and my demonstrations are going
to be mostly on on this on this console
alright so this is what you will see if
you create in AWS account right and as
soon as you log in this is the dashboard
that you will you will see I hope you
can see my terminal window as well I
might I might use this a little bit just
to show you how to connect to certain
interest resources so AWS has a number
of services right as you can see on your
screen
there's stuff in the compute category
right right here on the top left there
are services a storage databases
security and identity especially
identity in Access Management there's
also new stuff in analytics and big data
right and mobile services as well
alright so this number of services that
this was not always the always the case
right so initially database was a simple
infrastructure service and they've been
adding new services all the time okay so
now it is it is a wait bunker instance
comprehensive service all right but
today I'm going to talk about mainly
three things so one is easy to this is
simple virtual which will serve us like
it's a core service a simple
infrastructural element all right so
I'll show you how to set up a virtual
server maybe install have install your
application right this service also has
things like load balancers and auto
scaling groups right so we talked a
little bit about about these things I
also talked about s3 so this is an
important storage service right so a
very large
you know no limits on what you can store
right highly durable very fast right so
this is a very good service for things
like setting up websites storing your
database backups log files video files
anything grainy and lastly I'll try and
show you RDS as well so this is a
relational database service it helps you
run your my sequel databases for
instance right but you can also do a
Oracle Microsoft sequel alright
and what what it does for you is things
like backup database replication stuff
like that so it makes database
management very easy alright so let's
get started first I'm going to talk
about ec2 so easy to is elastic cloud
computer right so it's essentially very
flexible sort of service where you can
servers right and they can be of
different sizes and it's very very
simple let's let's see how to launch
launching instance by the way I also
point out right I am in a region called
US East so these are this list that you
see on the top right of the screen are
regions in AWS terminology these are
essentially the geographical locations
where the infrastructure will be located
all right and normally you want to pick
a region which is close to where your
users are this way you can avoid network
latency problems alright and within a
region you also have what is called
availability zones so these are sort of
you know independent independent units
within a region right and when I say
independent I mean there are supplying
independent right or their networking
may be independent so so if there's a
problem with with a power supplier it's
likely that only one availability zone
may be affected all right so what you
want to do is when you create
infrastructure you want to create them
in multiple zones within a region this
way you will have higher availability
all right so let me show you how to
launch a simple virtual server I'm going
to click on launch the first step is to
select what is called armies right so
this is MMS or machine image it's
basically a bundle of operating system
as well as software packages right so
you could have say and will do for
example right here I'm going to select
Ubuntu alright and it's also possible to
have armies with certain software
installed pre-installed so if you're a
lamp person Linux tepache my sequel PHP
right so it's possible to have armies
which have those software packages
installed already right so so that you
don't have to do it every time you
launch a server it's also possible to
create an army of your own application
so you know build a server completely
including OS software packages your
application
all the configuration that is required
to run your application right and then
convert that into an army all right so
this way you just build a server once
and then you can launch as many servers
as you like as many times as you like
from that from that army all right so
I'm going to select Ubuntu here for the
moment all right
this is instance types this is second
step so you have different sizes of
servers right so from very very small
like this one is the micro instance it
has one CPU and about 600 MBS of ram all
right
but you can have very large service as
well depending on the need
all right so for example this one here
it takes large is 32 reviews and 16gb s
of TVs of RAM
alright so for the moment let's let's
select micro instance I also want to
point out something out free tier right
so if you're creating a new interview
account a bunch of services are
available in the free tier so you will
not be billed for using these right for
a whole year so so this way you can open
your account and give any SS a try
without without any cost
alright so we've selected a micro
instance right I'm going to go into too
much detail at this time I'm going to
leave this alone
all right one important step is adding
storage alright so this is essentially
like your hard disks in a in a server
right so this is this is a route for you
which has the operating system
essentially right but you could add more
volumes this way so you don't have one
route volume and then perhaps one more
as a data volume alright but for the
moment let's stick to stick to one
volume now one more important thing is
security group so this is this is very
similar to I mean this is essentially a
fire bottle right so each component that
you create in a tab list has its own
firewall right so this is great from a
security point of view so let me create
a new security group let's call it web
server security group all right
and you can see here there are some
rules so this is SSH right so you can
connect to the server on SSH on 422
normally what you want to do is you know
restrict resource right so we don't want
people to connect to the server over SSH
so I'm going to say my ID but since this
is a web a web server we also want to
allow traffic on HTTP right
and normally HTTP is would have source
said to anywhere okay because you want
anybody in the world to access your web
server all right so that's it let's
review what we're doing so we're going
to launch a server which is an Ubuntu
machine alright with open to trusty this
is the version of alright and this is a
t1 micro a very tiny server which is
great for test purposes in certain kinds
of all kinds of needs
really all right so for example if you
have a controller that you want to run
you may want to run several web servers
behind a load balancer right so in that
case actual instances in the greatest by
all right we have a security group which
allows xsh access on a single IP address
right which is my my computer and it
also allows access on port 80 from
anywhere all right and as far as the
storage is concerned we have a one
volume of science 8gb all right so this
is it you can see there's this lot of
flexibility right you can change things
you can change instance type you can
change by whole rules you can add more
volumes all right so let's go ahead and
launch this all right one more thing is
before you launch the server you need to
select a key page
and so this is your public and private
key pair right this is what you use to
connect to the server using using SSH
now this is a good practice you always
should use key pairs and not use
passwords right so if you want to use
passwords alone you can do that by I
think in most cases you would do a part
of that all right so I'm going to select
an existing key prayer that I have and
launch this particular instance all
right so that's it let's take a look at
this
all right so while this is coming up
this may take maybe a minute right to
sort of boot itself up and if you look
at the bottom half of the screen you can
see things like the instance type like
here so micro instance there's a
security group right you can see the
rules here the firewall and it's in a
certain zone right so it's in one see
this can be important you'll see you'll
see how this becomes important and also
there's a public IP address right so
there's a public IP address which means
we can connect to this server from the
internet from the outside all right
you can also use the Public DNS which is
essentially the same thing as a public
IP address all right so I think the
server is in running state let's try and
connect to this so normally what you
would do is you would connect to the
server like this right so this is a
standard SSH connection so I specify the
my private key and the user to connect
to the servers Ubuntu and then I provide
the IP address
all right so that's it so you know we've
we've sort of connected over SSH to be
easy to instance we just started right
and now we are in the server and we can
run some come on so for example if you
wanna install some packages you would
you would do something like apt-get to
update the package list
mother so anyway so you know this is how
you sort of use the server right this is
standard Linux commands that you can let
you can run up the store alright so let
me exit this ok so just to summarize
right what we've seen is we launched an
ec2 instance this is a virtual server
and we sort of selected an army right
which is which is which was a no-bull to
army and we specified a micro instance
right so very small instance with about
600 MB of RAM we specified some firewall
rules we set up a volume EBS volume we
set up a key pair to connect to this
power right and in a minute or two you
have you have a server that is running
right so this is essentially ec2 for you
but you know that's not all right this
is this is just one maybe one sort of
virtual server ok so you know this is
not the only thing you can do with ec2
like this is just one server what you
would normally do especially in
production environments is is you could
you could run servers behind a node
balance right so what you will do is
let's take a look at this right so this
is a load balancer what you would do is
it's very simple very very simple to
create one
all right so so we're gonna load do the
load balancing across 480 you can of
course do it on other things as well for
example it's very common to do a load
balancing on on port 443 HTTPS all right
and you can also have security settings
for for the load balancer and we also
need to set up the health check
so what a load balancer can do is it can
it can sort of ping your ec2 servers and
if some of them or one of them is not
responding it will stop sending traffic
to it all right so this is what the
hell's Jake is and then you can simply
specify the sort of ec2 instances that
you want behind this behind this load
balancer
all right so a load balancer essentially
is it can distribute load across
multiple servers right and what you want
to do this is more servers will give you
scalability right they'll give you
better performance but they'll also give
you high availability because if one
server goes down the other servers can
continue right so you have higher
availability and you can also create
servers in multiple availability zones
right and like I said before a zone is
independent of each other of the other
zones so if there's any problem with
power or internet connections or any
sort of problem it's likely that only
one zone will be impacted so what you
normally do is create ec2 instances in
multiple zones and then use a load
balancer to distribute traffic on all
your instances
all right so this is how you create an
eld and you can see it's it's just a
five minute five minute job to get this
going
all right and what happens is in an dlb
you don't use IP addresses right in easy
- you saw that we use to my P address to
connect to it but in a load balancer you
have DNS names so something like this
all right and what you would do is you
point your DNS record your domain name
you our company comm meter say right so
you would create a DNS mapping mapping
your domain name to this DNS name here
right so this is how you would get that
working
so let me just show you guys how this
might look like so you can see here this
is a actual you know a functioning load
balancer right and this is sending
traffic doing ec2 instance that has a
web server it's drawn on it
alright so this is a quick introduction
to load balancers now a really cool
feature of ec2 is is auto scaling all
right so I'm not going to show you this
right now but let me just tell you
briefly what this is so essentially what
you can do is you can create a fleet of
easy to servers right so this is a group
of service and you specify a minimum and
a maximum
all right and then you can set up some
rules for the number of servers to
increase or decrease right so say
something like if the average CPU
utilization of the auto scaling group
goes above 90 per sec right for say 10
minutes
that means the infrastructure is
overloaded right so what you could do is
you the room could say let's add a
couple of more service all right and you
can have a corresponding rule to
decrease the number of servers as well
so you could set up a rule that says if
the average CPU utilization goes below
40 percent for say 10 minutes right then
remove a couple of cells right so this
gives you fantastic performance right so
your your capacity moves with the demand
and the other side is it also the
capacity reduces right when when the
load is less so this saves your cost
right so this saves you cost because you
might know this right you you probably
know this in AWS and other job computing
platforms you are built on a on an
hourly basis right so so for easy to
your paid per instance are right so if
you have instance is not running you can
save a significant amount of money
so that's my introduction - you see -
let me move on to something else okay so
let's talk about s3 so this is in the
storage and content delivery category
right
and before form is a simple storage
service so s3 is highly durable right so
the durability SLA offered by in abuse
is 99.99 alright so the chances of you
using any file or any sort of data is
next to next to nothing all right
it's a highly durable source you can
store anything right you can you can
store images video files slow trials
database files you can set up a website
using s3 right and maybe a cheap mess
well Beijing so how this works is you
simply create in a bucket
alright and so a bucket is
a way of organizing your weight so it's
just a just a just a bucket right and
within a bucket you could create folders
as well right so all right so so this is
what you can do and then you can upload
any sort of content right so all right
so let me just upload this file doesn't
matter all right so you can upload any
sort of file all right you can also use
automated scripts right so what you
seeing what you've seen so far is the
bear console right so this is a web
console that a device offers for you to
sort of manage your infrastructure but
there are also a command line tool kits
and software development kits available
right so you could write programs and
shell scripts to sort of interact with
the air base infrastructure okay so for
example you know let me let me show you
how to upload a file to this to this
bucket right so let's let me just create
a file alright and let's say you wanted
to upload this to to the bucket all
right so you could do something like
this
when it's anger
if I demo III file from computer right
to this to this bucket that we just
create it looks like that's done you can
also do an LS which is you know a linux
command for missing stuff right so you
could do something like this as well all
right so you can see here it shows you
the contents of that of that bucket
right so using commands such as these
you can write shell scripts right so
typically what you would do is you would
write in script to move your database
backup files into s3 right so a nightly
script perhaps running in a cron which
moves a database back up into into s3
all right um but there's a bunch of
other things as well that you can do
with this tree for instance let's look
at the properties of this of this bucket
all right and what you can do is you can
set up lifecycle rules by the way you
can
questioning which means it will maintain
all versions of certified right so this
is very useful for example if something
goes goes wrong all right
but what I want to show you is life
cycles so what you could do is configure
the rule all right that says say after
30 days move my files into another
storage plus within s3 right so s3 is is
great it's fast it's highly durable but
there are cheaper storage options this
way all right so one of the options is
infrequent access all right so this is
cheaper all right but the assumption is
you won't be retrieving these objects
too frequently all right so we've set up
a rule which says move a file from s3
standard to infrequent access storage
class after 30 days all right
and you can also say that after 60 days
a movie file to place here now place it
is fantastic by the way it's it's the
cheapest option right very very cheap
storage option great for say archives
buy things that you want to store you
need to store for example in a bank
regulators demand that data we get for
several years I think in India it's it's
seven years all right so so most of this
data is there are many years but it's
hardly ever retrieved right so what
you're looking for is a vey cheap
storage class and and that option is its
place here so what we're doing here is
after 60 days when the odds of meeting a
particular file is is very low we move
the car into place here all right and of
course you can also delete the file
let's say after after the year all right
so that's the rule that we have created
right and you can see the administration
is very easy now
like you just let's say you're doing
this for your log files for your
database files simply set up a script to
move the files into s3 and s3 will
manage the movement of the file from
standard to infrequent axis and then
replace it it's very very simple to use
s3 alright so so that's s3 now let me
show you one more thing and then we can
move on to questions all right so so the
third thing I will show you is RDS
relational database service alright so
this is a managed service and what this
means is it does some things for you
right so it does database backups for
example it does can do database
replication for you all right now you
should know that you could set up
database on ec2 service as well so you
you can take a virtual server on ec2 and
install your my sequel server on that
right you could do that and it would be
cheaper that way but if you're looking
for I mean if you been on the database
site right you would know that managing
backups is a is it's a headache it's so
it's complex and things like replication
criteria based replication setting up
master slave configurations making sure
they are functioning well those things
are hard things to do right so if you
don't have the expertise right or if you
rather not do those things right let's
say you're at well over you probably
want to focus on your on your
application right so for those sorts of
needs our DSS hardiest is fantastic so
let me just show you how to do this so
I'm going to launch a database instance
alright and you can see here there are
multiple engines available right so you
might prefer I mean if you have a
startup
perhaps you're using my sequel or poster
a sequel right but if you are on the
enterprise side perhaps you need to use
Oracle or sequel server right so
whatever your database engine you can
you can use that here so I'm going to
use my sequel and there's a couple of
options here so one is you install my
sequel as a on a single server right
that's that's something that you would
do for a development environment or a
test environment but you can also set up
a multi-asset
deployment right so this is a multi
availability zone deployment and
essentially means there's a master in a
slave right so there's a primary
database and they say there's a slave
database which is which is a replicator
right and what's important is this is
multiple availability zones right and
this this gives you high availability
right so if there's a problem in the
zone the RDS will switch you
automatically within a few seconds right
or maybe a couple of minutes at the most
to the secondary database right so you
have you have high availability that way
all right so for now I'm just going to
select the single instance right assume
this is a development or testing mode
all right and
and what you do is again it's way
similar to GC - right so you select your
instance type size of your server this
you will know if you know your
application you'll probably know what
you need right and even if you don't
even if you don't know how much it's
needed you can start with it's not small
right and you can change very easily so
this is a great thing about computing in
either place you can if you change your
mind if you need to change your mind you
can you can do that just a few clicks of
your so I'm going to select micro I'm
gonna select no to multi is it right
this would be yes if this was this for a
production environment with high
availability needs like and you can also
select the storage so this is
essentially be a storage for your
database right so you'll know how much
storage you mean for your for your
database and M your application right
and normally you can start small and
again this can be changed way easily
well so you should you would monitor
this and if it's approaching a 80% of
utilization you can simply simply change
or increase the allocated storage and
you don't want to have too much
initially because you're billed by the
amount of storage you use right so so
the building in the case of storage is
something like JB months right so the
more GB is you allocate the more you
will be billed so it makes sense to sort
of keep this to the minimum that you
need
all right hand
we just set up some some settings here
so the identifier of the instance so
this is the sort of identifier of this
server and a root username and password
explain
alright I'm gonna leave this these
details for now let's look at something
something so the thing that arias does
for you right that you that you that if
we do cannot do for you is it it does a
automatic backup of your database a
nightly backup right and you can specify
the retention period how long these
backups will be stored all right and
these makeups also allow for point in
time so let's say you apply a change to
your application and something something
goes horribly wrong right now and you
want to go back two hours from now so
you could do that because because of
these backups right so are these
maintains a backup file the Nike backup
and it also maintains transaction logs
right so it has it can do point in time
recovery for you all right
and it also applies not just wait right
so this is something that is also
painful right to apply security patches
and other types of patches to your
database server right so this is
something that RDS can can do for you
automatically
all right so that's it it's as simple as
that
all right so this this takes a bit of
time it has about five minutes or so
all right and let me show you how to
connect to this right so once this comes
up I have a running server here let me
show you how to connect to this so each
RDS instance will have what is called an
endpoint right so this is this is the
endpoint right
all right so what you do is let's say
you want to connect to this database
instance so you will connect to this you
know the way you connect to a to any my
sequiny so right except you will specify
the host option right so so you need to
specify the host option and there you
will you will specify the end point for
that particular case instance okay and
then the fourth this is standard my
sequel connection alright so this is the
port 3306 and then you specify the
username and then the password all right
so you can see you can connect to a to a
my sequence over this way right and
these same credentials you can create
more my sequel users and then and then
sort of use those those credentials in
this host the endpoint right in your
application its way so run your
application on ec2 instances and in
those instances configure the RDS host
name I can username and password so that
way you make easy to an obvious work
together
all right and you run your regular - it
will come apps that you're used to
all right so that's it I mean that's all
I wanted to show you this is the big
quick introduction to some of the core
services that a Tobias offers right so
easy to with virtual servers s3 is high
scalable highly durable general-purpose
storage right and audiences managed
relational databases all right so now
let me look at some of your questions
all right so okay so dawn your best is
how do you remove these server instance
so you don't get billed after 12 months
all right so look what you do is you go
to easy to write you have this server
that's running here all right and by the
way you don't need to wait for 20 months
like you don't even have to wait for
five minutes so that's a great thing
about cloud computing it's completely
you know there's no there's no upfront
commitment right so you can use a server
for five minutes and spend it so what
you do simply is go here and terminate
all right as simple as that
so it's build on an hourly basis so
right so if you use it for one hour or
less right you'll have you have a very
small hourly cost a few cents per hour
is how you know is what a micro instance
would cost okay
so there's no need to use it for twelve
months there is something called a
reserve instance right so if you know
that you you're gonna use certain
capacity for a long time then you can
reserve some capacity for 12 months or
more right and what you get is AB a
significant discount so something like
60% discount you could get if you commit
to using capacity for fill months or
more all right but otherwise the normal
instances are called on-demand instances
and you can just set them up and and
sort of terminate them whenever you're
done with them all right the next
question is from screen on and what
you're asking is does it a base support
application servers where applications
can reside on the cloud yeah so you know
these ec2 servers that you're seeing
right but these are these are
essentially virtual servers you can
install anything on them so whatever you
can do in your own servers you can do on
ec2 right so you could install an
application you can have another layer
with web servers but you could use RDS
for databases so whatever you you can do
outside of a the Lewis and Clark
computing you can you can do only to
this there's no problem at all
all right google your question is what
is a load balancer alright so this is
you know a load balancer is a component
right and what what happens is you have
when you have users coming to your site
right they will hit the load balancer
all right and the load balancers job is
to distribute traffic among among the
various ec2 instances or virtual servers
running behind the load balancer right
so if you have 10 servers right the load
balancer will distribute traffic to
those 10 servers all right and the
reason you want to have a load balancer
is you know multiple servers can give
you better performance it can give you
higher availability that so if one
server goes down there are nine of the
servers that are available like so your
user does not see CDE see the difference
right so multiple servers is good it
also gives you horizontal scalability
actually made if your usages is higher
right you need to add more servers so
that's called horizontal scalability so
instead of 10 servers
you could go to 20 servers right and and
then you have this many servers you need
to have a load balancer because there
needs to be certain component which will
move which will sort of distribute the
traffic all right so this is by the way
you know not in gator blue this feature
right so these are things which are
which are done outside of cloud
computing as well right but but you can
see it abyss provides that is way all
right
go cool your question is what's the
difference between s3 storage and
databases yeah so so databases are you
know like relational databases right
they are structured you know me do it
use them for structured data like say
employee records by know customer
records
whereas s3 is more like a file it's
actually called an object storage right
so I would I would say it's a fine
storage although you would commonly use
it to store your files right so it's an
object storage where you can have
bailout
sighs files say I think the maximum
limit is five terabytes right and you
can have any number of files and they're
kept waste space safety all right
so for example you know if you have a
youtube like application right you have
a relational database for say user
accounts right but the videos would be
stored in history all right so your data
will be stored in a in a database and
your videos would be stored in X 3 so
that's how that's how you would use
these various services often you need to
use both
alright so much me your question is how
is s3 available on your computer right
so here you're referring to these
commands here
and so you're referring to these
commands here so how is this available
on your computer did you mount anything
on your computer yes answer the question
right so what you need to do is you need
to install it's small utility
it's called AWS CLI all right so it's
just a command line to indicate made
available it's free of cost it's made
available by Kato place right so you
install it it's a base anthem
installation and you configure your
credentials right so you need to have
you need to have credentials so these
are like long long strings of
essentially keys like secret keys so
these are available in your account and
and those credentials have to be
configured in the command line tool kit
and once you do that you you can then
sort of run these commands all right and
the same thing you know if you want to
manage your infrastructure using scripts
you can also install this command line
tool kit on your servers which will
which will pay you will run your scripts
right so these can be installed on any
sort of computer whether it's a client
or a server alright one more question
here from we William ah I'm sorry if I'm
not pronouncing it right but your
question is if if you have cause to move
the files earlier to to any of the
cheaper storage making frequent access
or place here well then you get billed
for accessing them before 30 or 60 days
all right so okay so I think I
understand what you're saying is if you
need if you need to access the files
that have been moved to place your let's
date right like you need to access them
before 30 days the right video will be
built yeah so you know on lifecycle
rules was such that you know they were
moved into cheaper storage classes after
30 days in 60 days right so if you need
those files before 30 days then you'll
be fetching them from s3 right and there
are some some costs you know there are
s3 there may be some storage curves
there is some network cost so those
costs will apply right whatever the s3
costs are those windows will apply
and but even after they move to say
infrequent access of Glacia you can
still access them correct you can still
access them for example with glaze here
you you have certain sort of commands
that you can use to get your files back
right to your server but what happens is
laser is typically slower to retrieve so
it can take up to four hours for example
for you to get a funny but so that's the
trade-off
you get cheaper storage but but the
retrieval becomes slower
all right so I hope I answered your
question but basically you know if
you're accessing them before 30 days or
60 days you will access them from from
that particular storage class in which
it is store right not in any other
storage case
all right cool your question is how do
we install our software in ec2 yeah so
how do you know I'm not very familiar
with it
right if you can install our on say a
Windows server or a Linux server right
in your in your own premises in your own
server room in your own data center in
your own laptop right if you can do
those things then you can do that on ec2
as well right because you simply you
know is simply connected to ec2 the way
I had showed right you you use SSH
connect to ec2 and then download the our
software and run the installation we'll
come on
so the same thing that you do outside of
cloud computing you can you can do all
easy all right
Shriram your question is is there any
support for a continuous build and
integration yeah so this is also a good
question so look what a debase is doing
is it's always expanding its list of
services right and it was it used to be
an infrastructure as a service very
simple storage networking compute
capacity right but now it is adding more
and more services so for example a
single office works right so if you're
familiar with chef or puppet right these
are configuration management tools this
is something that you can you can look
at all right there are other services as
well
for example elastic Beanstalk so this
makes it very easy for you to deploy
your application so all you have to do
is
creative application and with a few
steps right the service the application
will be deployed on service even if even
if the servers are not balanced and have
auto scaling and complex infrastructure
elements right plastic load balance in
astok a beanstalk will do that on your
behalf right so as a developer you
simply upload your code and the
infrastructure is created by Beanstalk
for you right and Beanstalk also makes a
Bey easy to deploy it changes to your
application for its own version to
version 3 can be deployed to your
servers with just a you know one or two
clicks of controller of your mouse all
right so there are multiple sources of
multiple services even cloud formation
is another one that you might want to
look at right so this is something that
allows you to create the infrastructure
using template files like some a simple
JSON like template files can be used to
codify your infrastructure and simply to
supply the template to create the
infrastructure right so some of these
services I think I'll have to sort of
evaluate to see if these meet your needs
all right Tyrone your question is does
it provide a disaster recovery right so
yes this might be an old question I'm
not sure what you're referring to but in
general right either this is very good
for us read carefully so for example you
have multi a set deployments right so
multi multiple availability zones give
you very high availability and with RTS
you could do master-slave replication
right so if there is a stirring in one
zone the the slave becomes the primary
database right
with only feticide you can have load
balancer and have ec2 instances in
multiple zones right so this way there's
a disaster
one zone keeps functioning all right and
you can also do across regional sort of
disaster recovery so you could copy your
amis and database snapshots to another
region right and if there's a problem in
your primary region you could sort of
quickly provision infrastructure in the
second the
okay and there's also route 53 here so
this is a networking service essentially
in a DNS service so you could do things
like latency based probing which which
is like an active-active
disaster recovery configuration right
you could do DNS failover this way so so
this is pretty good this way all right
Gaurav your question is can I suspend an
instance so that I don't get built
during the time I need it okay yeah so
good question so you could you could you
know what you could do for example is
you have a server here right you could
stop it instead of terminating it so so
right here instant state and stop right
so this this puts the machine in a sleep
State and you're not built for using the
server right but you are paid for the
storage that may be attached to these
servers which is normally storage is a
very small component of every all right
so this is something that you could do
or you could sort of take a snapshot
like you can take a snapshot of your
volume all right you can just take a
copy of this volume all right and when
you need n and then terminate the server
right and when you need it again from
this snapshot you can sort of create
create an observer right so there are
multiple multiple options it's very very
easy to do what you what you looking
yeah all right so okay Ajitha your
question is how will licensing work for
operating system and databases yeah so
this is also a good question so normally
you know you could of course use things
like my people or Linux right and the
hourly rate that you pay is you know
essentially includes the server cost the
cost of running the server right but for
certain commercial products like Oracle
databases right the cost of Licensing is
built into your hourly rate okay or
perhaps a Windows Server on the ec2 side
you would find that the cost we hardly
cost is slightly higher and that's
because of the licensing cost okay and
there are some options for bringing your
existing licenses as well all right so
you might have invested as an enterprise
into Oracle licenses right
and you want to waste those licenses so
you can talk to it of this and sort of
bring them over into a SS alright and
Laxmi your question is how how is high
availability possible with easy - yeah
so you know first of all easy to
accelerate tiny abit lecture it has I
think a semi of 99.95%
right and what you can do is you can
create multiple ec2 instances right so
that gives you higher availability you
can create auto scaling groups these are
groups where if there's a hardware
failure the auto scaling group will
automatically replace it all right and
you can also sort of set up ec2
instances in multiple zones so that it
is the zonal period failure as well your
your application will keep running okay
and there are complex configurations
where you can create cross regional
infrastructure as well so let's so
basically the several options you know
there's load balancers auto scaling
groups there are zones the region's
there's route 53 or DNS failover lots of
things you can do and if you look at the
architecture white papers on Oedipus
this is another PI I guess and return
once again good question do the
applications need to be developed in a
different way in order to be deployed on
the cloud so no you know they what you
can do right if you are building an
application from scratch right you can
take advantage of the capabilities of
cloud but so you can design your
applications in a new way but which is
which is better
alright so for example because cloud
infrastructure is is you can throw them
away right so what you normally would
wanna do is store sessions in a no
single database for example like or in a
cache cache server like you want to
store sessions in our on the only ec2
instance that your variable right so
there are a lot of things that you can
change in your architecture to take
advantage of the player but if you
already have an application right which
runs on your own existing servers right
so you don't need to make any change
that you can simply move them over
providing all the services that you need
right are available in the creative
place so so yes and no is actually right
and existing applications that you move
right away and then look to optimize
later but new applications you can you
can start build it all right this one
question here from Spyros how does the
file synchronization occur between a
client workstation and a ec2 file server
on a tab us with s3 storage alright so
you know first of all if we two
instances don't use s3 right so this can
create applications which use both so
your application will run on ec2 and you
can have certain files or guest you
could do that but otherwise s3 and ec2
are not sort of integrated in any way
like so these are completely separate
services what you have normally is with
these people you have EPS for yours last
block store right so great so the volume
that you see here is actually an EPS
volume and this is linked to attached to
a to eight ec2 server
okay so EVs is like like your Nass
weight or mass force and so this is what
normally happens and so the
synchronization is concerned you there's
no synchronization as such but you can
build some things you want to but
there's no synchronization between apply
until the EBS storage okay with s3 what
you can do is you could sort of set up
some sort of synchronization you could
sort of for example you should copy in
your log files right from a local server
to s3 you could sort of set up a
synchronization with the command so you
you run a command curve C and then it
sort of make sure that the files are the
same on both sides so you could do that
with s3 alone and easy to is a different
thing it's it's sort of a virtual server
and Ramesh how is it a blessed load
balance different from other load
balancers they have file so you know I
don't think it's very different in terms
of functionality right it does the same
job essentially though balancing
distributing traffic it does a Hilton
I don't know if the f5 can do a hike
straight all right so it's instances are
not Haley doesn't send traffic to those
those servers and it's designed to work
with linear region but across multiple
zones so that's that's how it works but
functionally I think is very similar to
other low balances all right so there's
one question here from Devon you're
asking do we need to make one or more
server per load balancer or the load
balancer functioning Erebus can cover it
no so you don't need to create any ec2
instance to become a load balancer right
so you don't need to know that what you
will do simply is come here and create a
blue pencil right here all right and
once you have a load balancer you simply
specify the ec2 instances that it needs
to distribute traffic to all right so so
Lakshmi your question is by creating a
virtual server we said any option to
select the number of network cards so no
you know there is there is no option at
the right now but I mean no option by
default as you saw in the screens there
was no option there but there is there
isn't the goal eni elastic network
interface and you should also look up a
virtual private cloud okay so this is
this is essentially a sort of virtual
network that you create within a tab
list and you can have servers installed
within within OB PC alright so there you
do have our options of assigning
multiple sort of IP addresses those
instance right so you have to look up
the documentation but but it's not a
straightforward selection of network
cards in the easy to launch screens
alright cinder ah your question is can
you talk a bit about subnets and what is
the difference between a subnet and a
security group all right so so security
group is essentially a fireball right
all right and what you can do is you can
create any number of security groups say
a one one firewall for the web server
layer right so you may have 10 bit
servers and all of them are protected by
a same by the same firewall
and in a web server firewall will allow
traffic on port 80 and block everything
else all right
you may have a security group for a
database layer right and there you'll
allow traffic on port 3306 which is my
sequel port let's say right and you'd
also allow traffic only from the web
server or application service not from
anywhere hits so so that's that security
groups our firewalls right and a subnet
is is a network subnet right so so for
example at home you might have a submit
which which has a number like one ninety
two dot one sixty eight dot 2 dot X
right and in the same network you may
have another subnet called 192 dot 168 1
dot X right so so essentially you have a
network and within a network you can
have a sub mix ignore one or more
subjects so subnet is essentially a
networking concept so it's a set of IP
addresses I think so for example as a
subnet can have 250 256 IP addresses
right
so that's natural submit this and
security group is over here the firewall
already and Nagendra your question is
can be independently upgrade or
downgrade only the RAM of the instance
no so what you can do is you can change
the instance type right so so when you
change the instance type you do change
the RAM or when you do change the RAM
but in some cases you may also change
the email so change these CPUs well it's
a poor example here you can change the
instance type right right now the server
is running so it's grayed out but if the
server is stopped you can change the
instance type and just look at the
documentation for what are the resources
with each instance type right so let's
go you have to do it you can't simply
produce the RAM you can change the whole
instance type all right Gaurav it's an
option for database for database
replication so yeah so you know with RDS
right with RDS you can do database
replication
using the multi a set deployment option
all right
you know remember if we do is just a
virtual server right so if you're doing
database replication on two servers
right on your own
whatever you can do outside of Erebus
you can do one alright so you can take
two ec2 instances make one of primary
and and the other of slates over right
so all those things possible alright so
don't worry your question is how do we
create other servers which which have
the same specification and configuration
as the existing one
yeah so this is also a very good
question all right so what you do
normally Dohan is you you have an
instance right like this one and you
connect to it you install yourself well
you you create your you install your
application to install all the packages
that you need right you may need PHP you
need my sequel you need watch a for
example right so you install all of that
and then once once the server is
installed tested right what you do is
you simply simply come here and you
create an image alright so with this
image this becomes an army essentially
right and then you can use this image to
create as many servers as you want and
those other servers could be exactly the
same as has this one alright so this is
something that's very common way this is
something that you have to do and of
course there's a lot there's a way to do
it
alright so do we have god of your
question is do we have intrusion
prevention like firewall and
anti-malware services running to protect
the applications so who's you have
firewalls right so the security group
that we saw here right you can see here
as way this is a firewall alright and
you can create multiple firebox you know
multiple multiple layers of fireworks
for example one player web server one
player application servers on pure
database servers all right you can
create your infrastructure within a
virtual private cloud
alright and you also have access control
lists so so there's like another
firewall at a networking never this way
alright so that is I mean from a
security point of view a networking
going to do this database has a lot by
the power it has a lot of
but as far as malware is concerned those
are things I think that you have to
install right so if you're installing
some malware protection
I got software on your existing servers
you can do that you can do that on ec2
service as well
all right so remember you see too many
reduce servers are exactly the same as
servers running in your own greatest
interest right so you can do the same
thing here as well all right and sriram
you're saying in the main panel you saw
an application gateway so let me just
take a look here
Oh API gateway maybe right so you you
probably mean API gateway so this is
essentially you know a service which
lets you publish certain API X right so
you create arabia's those great guys
could be so simple for example lambda
functions so you can create a small
program using lambda and then publish it
where the where the API gateway right so
it sort of gives you a managed gateway
service for your API so right so you
don't have to throw provision for for a
B X all right so good for things like
web services right or REST API s-- that
you may want to create all right so okay
I think that's the that's the set of
questions I'm seeing right now so I
think we can end this session I hope I
hope you learn something you found this
useful
all right so thank you very much for
joining